welcome to episode 127 of film courage
my name is karen warden my name is david
brandon just like that we're back in
studio here karen we are yeah it's funny
how a week it goes by very fast and then
here we are and hopefully very excited
each one of you out there is here back
with us today our guest is actor writer
director and musician
steven morimarco steve is a graduate of
the ucla school of theater film and
television he recently completed his
first indie feature
the great intervention steve also sings
in his own original soul punk swing band
called the abe lincoln story and is an
actor here in los angeles he's also
worked with america's funny funnyman
neil hamburger on several concert dvds
steve more marco has written two
articles
i guess you know steve we can't contain
this
we're gonna open that mic right up right
now awesome but we're gonna continue to
talk about you though steve um you know
he's written two articles four
filmcurse.com both are great um they
both received quite a lot of reads
um one is entitled fudge or i should say
fud zoloft make indie film yeah and the
others i said did i say that right you
know that was you isn't the right
emphasis well i don't know why
can we uh we can't curse on la talk
radio yeah you can oh i think
but did i put it well i think i changed
it to that because you just have the
symbols right yeah but fudge zoloft
works budget just fudge it people
fudge the zoloft
and then the other one is called how to
make a movie on five
thousand dollars and that was just
republished on indy indiewire exactly
and steve will be screening his film the
great intervention at our september film
courage interactive at the downtown
independent in los angeles on monday
september 26 2011 beginning at 7 p.m in
the film the great intervention steve
plays a single unemployed 40-something
actor slash musician who believes he has
finally been discovered by a documentary
film crew after years of languishing and
obscurity and the film as steve writes
about in his article fudge zoloft is an
embellishment of his own life and served
as a catalyst out of his own real-life
depression please welcome to the film
courage studio mr steve more marco hello
hello how are you i'm fantastic thanks
for asking
it's great to finally meet you i've had
so many email exchanges with you it's
nice to see you in person and and and
get to meet the real steve behind it
maybe okay all right well the many faces
but you know it's hard when you meet
people online because you just kind of
never know once you see them uh what
you're going to get and and that leads
us in actually to our first question
okay um you know it's always great when
someone is responsible with their emails
and they get back to you in a timely
manner
are you often surprised by artists who
aren't accountable with their emails and
their phone calls
well i have a 10-piece band like i said
so yes it it definitely does happen
there's you know and sometimes it's
misunderstands but i did recently have
an issue with one of the members of the
band i couldn't get in touch with them
email trade facebook them pick up the
phone their phone is disconnected i'm
like ah you know uh yeah and sometimes
it is you know it seems so simple just
to take one second and
do an email people get busy but uh you
know everybody there is very there's a
lot of different communication methods
some people
you know you have to call
some people you have to email some
people you have to text only some people
you can facebook message i don't know
there's
it's great and it's also maddening at
least like i said in my
with the
dealing with a 10-member group
you know okay okay uh charlie doesn't
check his email i better facebook him or
better
i haven't heard from pat better text him
you know whatever but it's you know
their life
their preferred method
i try and accommodate right
like we all do so you know yeah it is
frustrating people don't you know i
think there was actually a new york
times article recently about
email uh communication like that you
send something you don't hear returns
like did they get it
you know that is a neurosis i think we
have well communication communication
commend you on that that's great oh
thank you thank you thank you so you
were here today partly because of the
dark days that you went through in 2008
and you know we feel this interview is
where we would sort of like to begin
with this um let's begin so let's let's
kind of go there take us to some one of
the hardest part
emotionally into it no uh 2008 yeah it
was very uh just
uh you know i've had a i've had a few uh
crises in my life existential crisis and
uh that was me and they you know they're
always
they're always
not fun and uh
uh you think this it's the worst one and
you know of course that was the worst
one because it was the most recent but
you know you get in your 40s and you you
sort of look around and you know you're
like what what is going on with my life
you know
i i don't have a job you know like the
top the stock market was
everything was tanking you know the the
recession had started and you know
everything just got really really hard
and i had broken up with a girlfriend
who we lived together and she left and
uh that kind of thing it was just it was
just it just you just you just start
having anxiety attacks you're like
you're like i'm 42. oh my god i have
nothing what am i gonna
do you know and so i just started waking
up
in the morning
freaking out a little bit and i was
trying to keep it under control and
uh i
you know i i i
try exercise and then then i went to the
doctor for like a checkup and now the
the doctors nowadays have the um
mood wellness like section of your thing
which you know i it's kind of cool but
you know so i was i was depressed so i
kind of checked the lawn mower she she's
like oh you should try this lexapro it's
very mild it'll help you
and i was like i'd been on
antidepressants before and yeah it
wasn't psyched
to obviously go down that road but i
felt okay maybe maybe she's right maybe
i need it if it's that
maybe it'll just help me get through
this
and i had like the worst reaction on it
i really like it was the opposite of
mild and the opposite of calming and it
just you know because it's your brain
and everybody's brain is different and
i've talked to people since then who've
had similar reactions but i just i
really like couldn't sleep i couldn't
calm down i couldn't
stop thinking like crazy thoughts and
then they would be like oh no no just
just give it a week or so to kick in and
then you're like i can't survive
you know
so we had to go off those meds and then
i went down to san diego for a couple
weeks and just you once you get in the
the medication world it's very hard to
kind of get out for
a while um
and i just i was they tried you know all
this different stuff and i just it
finally kind of clicked in
with the abilify and the zola for a
little bit but then like
my personality was gone oh i don't know
that's one thing you sort of just become
like muted
yeah muted and
and uh and then we did it again and then
you know whatever and then i started
i do a lot of other things acupuncture
just you know trying to get myself
and one of the things that i i you know
i enrolled in like a screenwriting
course because it's like okay you know
really that's the thing i
you know one of the things i can do and
you know
gives you myself a project i'm gonna
write a movie
and um you know that's something to
focus on instead of you know stuff i
can't control
right i just want to go back quickly to
something that you said in the beginning
and that is that you would wake up with
this pressure right was the pressure
coming from you or from your sort of
support system
just for me really i felt like
you know my parents have always been
super supportive and just uh always
there for me and you know
emotionally and and uh it just
it just was it was like you know like a
clock going off in your mind like all of
a sudden that that happens sometimes
like oh you know
when you know
yeah there wasn't there wasn't a
complete explanation for it in some ways
it wasn't like you know i did have
traumatic things going on like said
breakups and that kind of thing but it
was
it just i i
it you know i it's hard to say it was it
was a you know the perfect storm as they
say and it just
i just all of a sudden yeah i couldn't i
your mind plays tricks on you of course
and you start going down this spiral and
you know
it's it's really really hard to to to
get out of it even no matter how you
know and i felt like i was running away
from a black hole at one point really
trying to not yeah i have get i'd get up
in the morning and you know run around
the block you know and try and to calm
down and you know it like you know and
you know anything i could think of
to to not like have the ruminating
thoughts and all that and it just
it it didn't work and you know and and
part part of me is like well god if i
didn't take the lex pro would i be
okay or would i
you know it's hard to truly know but you
know i'm kind of against those
medications now
you know and i i did eventually
through you know the the writing of the
film i i actually didn't in the
screenwriting class i actually didn't
write this film it was sort of a side
idea that was
semi-inspired but you know i was trying
to write my mainstream film that i'm
still you know trying to work on top
secret but
um
uh is is it yeah is this making sense do
it um
should i keep going i mean you're
speaking of these dark days you know so
in our darkest days you know we often
need a glimmer of hope
something we can grab on to right you
know our strengths friends family
something that they pull on they're just
so just a goal what for you steve what
were the thoughts that were that sort of
got you through those those times and it
eventually got you out of that that mold
well it was i i i do
credit um
a lot just
focusing again on
myself and my creativity and or whatever
and just trying to
yeah trying to uh
trying to
yeah pour myself into our artistic
projects or force myself to
if that's the word but i i i guess i
just
uh
yeah it really was like you know i i i'm
gonna say a lot of you know finding
about the
focusing to write a um
a screenplay was what was a good idea
like it really like i said like i could
yeah give myself a goal and kind of
imagine and try and
to have the the writing discipline so
that was that was helpful in addition to
like exercise yoga
you know acupuncture even you know the
medication therapy you know it was all
part of the mix but yeah the goal was
just to um
to
to yeah feel feel safe and happy and you
know confident again and
so well so many people are afraid to try
so many things for fear of you know not
doing them perfectly
why did you start during this very
fragile time
um
yeah i didn't have anything to lose okay
kind of yeah i just i i just felt like
um
i just uh yeah especially because it was
you know i didn't look he said i want i
want to write a screenplay just to make
myself feel better and like i said i
have
you know ideas like okay what's the
perfect mainstream screenplay that's
going to get me noticed in hollywood or
whatever and that was my idea
just just uh
ironically because
yeah i yeah i just wanted to
just write kind of like a big budget
romantic comedy
idea that i had and
um that i kind of was working out but uh
but then as you start being creative
again you're out your mind starts
obviously you're working like and your
mind starts churning so
uh so as i'm i'm doing that and you know
one of the things in the class we had to
like you know just you just start
listing
ideas for movies you know just whatever
you can think of and riff off you know
he had there's some sort of formula but
i but one of the ideas i had on the list
that i
didn't do was like mom has to get son
married and job and you know
dot dot dot
and i was like okay
interesting you know whatever i thought
about i'm like but why you know it
didn't really it was just an idea that
just a side idea and then
i st you know obviously i was super
depressed and you know going through
this
and i and i just started thinking about
that show intervention of course and um
and i was thinking like oh you know am i
hardcore enough for an intervention show
you know what would my parents well if i
had to be on the show you know
that was part of the idea that you know
uh yeah how what what apparent parents
what would they do to you know people
are trying to get the people on
intervention shows all the time but what
if they're not like this drug addict
thief you know
cutting me you know something so uh but
then and then the other idea was like
when i was thinking about the show you
watch the show and it's
you're always like how the hell do they
do this people let them film them you
know like doing taking the drugs and
then i was like oh they must pump them
up flatter them in some way say they're
a film crew and we're doing a
documentary on you
and then i was like oh yeah okay so if
that happened to me they would come and
they would talk about you know my music
and
acting and try and pretend that yeah it
was a film crew doing and i was like oh
that you know that's that's funny
because you know every actor has that
dream or musician like you know i've saw
i've been watching you on the internet
or i've you know because nowadays it's
sort of plausible so
when those things sort of clicked i was
like okay oh
yeah if my parents you know yeah they
want i'm middle-aged they want me a job
get married you know before they die or
whatever
and if i was trying to get an
intervention show and then i realized
okay it could be a little documentary if
you know semi documentary
and then i just yeah i would just sleep
on it and just start thinking of little
other little weird things of my life
that could somehow work in
to the movie
and then i just yes
it just it really did kind of
steamroll from there like as a side
thing from my quote you know mainstream
movie and i was like oh wait i got
i have a movie i think i can i think i
can just film it myself i don't need to
try and shop it to hollywood or
i i i think i can do this i wasn't
obviously a hundred percent sure but i
was i was pretty sure and so and then i
was mentally thinking about okay well
you know good it's it's about me so
i'll be in it we don't need to you know
pay an actor
i'll have to direct it too i guess
uh
and you know you know and all these
things feel like we can use my house a
lot of it'll be in my house uh i don't
need a
any fancy sets
uh we can my dad's an actor you get him
aboard my mother is uh they're remarried
she lives in reno but and then so i this
great actress i knew from uh classical
theater lab that i i'm a member of uh
karen tarleton
she was always just great and i just
immediately thought of her i believe
he's like she's perfect for my mom and
uh you know i emailed her she's like yes
you know
so and i like that hybrid fantasy truth
fiction kind of thing where it it
crosses you know it's it's
it you know it has elements of the truth
but it's it's it's fake
you know we're going to continue talking
about okay you know the the the great
intervention i'd like to take it back a
little bit though to continue to put
everything in perspective but this isn't
the first time that you've that you've
tried to get a feature film off the
ground how many how many efforts have
you had and what's been sort of the
deciding factor between those that you
weren't able to get off the ground in
this one
well
i haven't got tried i haven't had too
much success i've been working one of my
dream projects as a this uh neil
hamburger who you mentioned before we
wrote a screenplay uh
like 10 years ago and that was the idea
was you know he's kind of an
up-and-coming comedian and uh you know
we can get the money for this and you
know it'll be you know and it's it's uh
it was hard because uh we i shot 10
minutes of that movie as an idea of
maybe a trailer we turned into a little
short film called left 4 dead in
malaysia and
kind of trying to at the time that
seemed like the way to get uh
movies made you do a short
bit of the film and kind of show it to
people saying this is what it's uh like
and
and we just we kind of
we just didn't have any luck i i i
partly
you know we don't i didn't know what i
was doing sort of and um
you know it's just hard to get
people to give you thousands and
thousand dollars and you know we didn't
know what the budget
we would need but when i shot that film
in two thousand
four
shot on super 16
black and white i kind of was going for
this you know david lynch-ish kind of
thing and uh and that cost five thousand
dollars for ten minutes so i was like oh
god okay five thousand dollars for that
okay times 90 you know at least
it's to expect you know i can't do it
myself so
but now obviously the technology has
keep going down and down and now i'm
like i think we could do that movie for
ten thousand you know so maybe that's
the next one in the pipe you know but i
feel like uh
the costs have just gotten really
really gotten uh affordable for for a
lot of films that used to cost
thousands and thousands of dollars if
you're smart you can do them for a
reasonable
price you know at least your own
personal film you know maybe it won't be
in sundance or the
uh
the you know the sunset five even or
anything but
you know maybe you'll have house parties
you know or
but it is possible to make a film
and get it seen by you know a decent
amount of people
if you work at it you know
you know is is this film redemption for
you stephen oh totally and what kind of
expectations do you have for it
it's already exceeded my expectations
i'm here on film courage i mean that's
that's big that uh uh
i i i tried to keep my expectations
super low i just really wanted to
just do it just just do it see if i
could take this german of an idea
you know get the money raise the money
on kickstarter
follow through with it do it
i even you know edited it and the whole
thing and then um
i you know i i i it looks like we're
gonna have a screening in new york too
um so new york and la that's good i've
submitted to sundance of course i've
submitted to slam dance you know you you
do the festival thing with some
hopes but it it it can't help but make
money because it technically didn't cost
money for me to make
so every dollar is you know because i'm
try
i also realize too that like
spending thousands and thousands of
dollars on advertising you know
isn't going to bring
in my mind is not going to bring in
any more money you know if i spend 30
thousand dollars on advertising maybe
may to make you know five thousand in
sales or something it doesn't like
i just i just have to do with a lot of
thing you know pray for some kind of
viral video
and or word of mouth and you know with
film is is kind of a good thing for word
of mouth
uh people like the obscure movies kind
of sort of so it
it's possible you know and i'm and i'm
trying to uh
like said reach out uh
to to podcast and you know writing about
the experience of the film
uh to help other people to make films
to also promote the film so
um
and and and do you feel like that you've
waited too long that you should have
been doing some of this work
um you know as you were writing the film
should you have been building an
audience for the film then did you feel
like you're playing ketchup right now i
i don't really feel like i'm playing
ketchup um
i i read somewhere too and i think it's
true you know at least for this kind of
level um
you just kind of
go again i i i think in a sense it's
it's good timing right now this is all
kind of lined up magically this
starting right now as my official
publicity blitz has begun
this is it we're at the gate i have a
good friend is who's helping me with the
publicity
and like a month into it that's good
like you don't want to start i mean i
have been publicizing it from
kickstarter day one and even before that
the campaign and i've got my core
backers who know about this film courage
thing about the movie coming up so it's
all been
it is such a slow process in a sense
yeah i i don't feel like i wanted to
hype it a year ago too much because then
it's like people waiting a year and a
year everybody you know you only know
what you what movie you're going to see
maybe the week before unless you know
it's some avatar kind of thing that they
roll out this heavy campaign so so i
think it's good i think you know once
you get a start
a date uh any kind of screening like a
month before is when you really take out
the big guns at least that's what it
seems like
we like the way you're taking out the
big guys
we are in studio with filmmaker actor
and musician steven morimarco you can
see his film the great intervention in
less than a month
it's going to be screening
monday september 26th at 7 pm at the
downtown independent
you can connect with steve on twitter at
more markable and you can find out more
about his film by going to the great
dot info just just great intervention
dot info know thee
oh that was my bad how did they get in
there no i did that
okay oh really okay
i can't without responsibility
all right uh so steve your father is in
the film of course and he plays your
father as well and he's also in an
article that was i believe on aol news
that was a great maybe that i think your
friend sent us when we first freaked out
uh or uh right right uh that was my fake
publicist section oh is that what it was
who was the [ __ ] myra that's my middle
name and then the street i used to live
or fred rainey i think it was
because that's i grew up on rainey
street that's what so my my friend from
aol was kind of like you should have you
know fake publicist name and then they i
i did it a little bit and then somebody
called me and they're like is fred there
i'm like oh you have the wrong number
right like oh wait wait no no no it's
it's it's me so i'm trying not to do
that i don't know it seemed like but it
maybe made it more semi-professional but
it works
with all the emails we always get we
always wonder like hmm is this is this
actually the person who pretended
you know my email exchange with fred was
very right
i think i
tried to switch it over as
instantaneously as possible but uh it
was very smooth
that's quite a name though for a
publicist just fred you yeah i like that
well that's my father's name that's my
middle name oh okay well
it worked i like the name foreign
a link to this aol news article it was
great and it was where your father was
interviewed for part of the the article
and he says you know the great
intervention is as much about his son's
depression as it is about a common
problem among people who live in l.a and
he says a lot of people they move to los
angeles when they're young trying to
make it in movies and then at some point
you wake up and then you're in your 40s
and you're still trying to make it
and your dad i believe is a retired
english professor is that correct yes so
there's a scene in the film not to give
away any spoilers or anything where he
compares himself
at his age 42
to yourself can you tell us about that
oh yeah yeah uh yeah that you know that
was one of the things of course and it's
true too because and it's you know true
specifically for my family but for
everybody but you know my father during
the intervention scenes like you know
when i was 43 you know i had a career i
was midway to family i you know
he was he was a phd professor at san
diego state university and uh
yeah two kids i was a teenager by then
and you know but
but that is also like i feel like our my
generation a lot is like somehow we got
this weird double childhood that
now seems more commonplace but you know
uh
when obviously my parents and some
people got married when they were 21 22
had kids then had families a career
started it early now
it's not only more difficult it's just
it just takes yeah it just takes longer
but now people are getting married in
the 30s 40s of course even and having
children later and later so families are
you know it's just it's just a different
dynamic but you know the i when when we
did the intervention scene um
i invited all my friends over to my
house and i basically said come over and
then
gave everybody pen and paper and just
said you know write what you want about
me real or false you know this is an
intervention
you know and again i tried to sort of
say i i didn't want it to be like a drug
or alcohol kind of thing
i thought it was you know it was just
funnier if it's like you know you're a
terrible
musician wake up or you know that kind
of thing it just fit more for the uh
for the movie so ever you know so and
everybody just really uh it was a very
interesting experience to be you know at
your own intervention or sort of
direct your own intervention or whatnot
so yeah it was it was it was some people
did say a few things and that you know
it definitely
it was a little
gut you know stab when you know he said
that or but it was you know it's true
that's that's you know i i i you know we
don't uh we're often
nowadays our generation we're not as
successful as our parents or or
at least in the traditional terms you
know that they
were used to uh the world has changed
people people are uh
you know
right well i mean there's not the those
jobs out there you go and you get your
pension and all of that and exactly it
is a different place i'm wondering in
this whole gen x sort of thing do you
think there are a lot of other gen xers
out there that have heard the same thing
from their parents oh is this a common
thread that's what i
that's what i'm hoping
in a sense
just because i you know i want people to
relate to the movie a lot to to to be
like that with parents you know you know
because it is people and you know
obviously i'm trying to say with the
movie also don't give up your dream you
know
uh even if people try and force you to
get you know but
but um
uh
yeah i think i i i think that is it it's
really really hard and now with this uh
depression slash recession that keeps
going on and on it's just
harder and harder for uh
people just i it's it's no longer
um
it's no longer sort of shocking when
people move back to with their parents
at any age anymore kind of it's like
it happens you know a lot people have to
do it it just
it doesn't um
you know there's
a lot of people are in survival mode now
it just it it happens and an artist you
know it's just like when you're young
you obviously of course think you're
gonna by the time you're 30 or even 40
that you're going to be
at this plateau and maybe you're not
prepared when you get there
to that age things aren't but everybody
i you know i've talked to people you
know everybody's always striving for
that next level you're always
you're always trying to um
everybody's always got a little better
than you but you got to kind of look
around and say okay well i got this
i got that you know
so well yeah i was reading an article i
think it's called the boomerang effect
right people are going back but i think
too in this new age where nothing is
guaranteed anymore and people who were
making you know six figures before and
then find themselves back at minimum
wage jobs i think people are now kind of
going with that and this is going to
sound you know follow your heart type of
the thing because
there's there's no guarantees anymore
yeah exactly which is which is great in
in in some senses just that if p
if you got nothing else to
do you might as well yeah you might as
well do it you might as well make that
film you know but but but i but i think
you know what i was trying to say with
like make a movie for five thousand
dollars or whatever
we don't need to do the hollywood
shuffle thing or whatever where you max
out your credit cards or you you know
you borrow from you know family and it's
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
dollars
to make these movies uh
that aren't going to be profitable or
or be seen anywhere
traditionally you know there's a whole
machine for that that's uh
very difficult for us
people to get into but but again that
you can realize
i i think of a good portion of
films
that
that artists can write for a reasonable
amount of money and then hey you've got
a film you know that's your one up you
know so now i've
i've made a film so hopefully the next
one will be
a step up you know
you know it used to be obviously like i
said yeah you pour in all this money and
you really hope and that's it you shot
your wad if it doesn't succeed you're
broke and in debt and uh
the film's never going to see the light
of day and now
because of kickstarter 2 again there's
just like a way
to raise uh
amounts of money expose your
self to
artists and people or uh you know make
awareness that you are doing this and
make it an evolving process and then
have a product at the end that um
is viable at some level if it's not like
i said in
at your local cineplex at least it's on
your local youtube or something you know
you know the diy trend is certainly upon
us and that's what you're speaking of
stephen you know more and more artists
are taking it into their own hands
um and you certainly embody the movement
with what you've done with the great
intervention um and overall i mean
you've done it you've done it both ways
you've done it where you've gone out the
traditional way where you've submitted
your head shot you've drawn it for
auditions still still and
you're still doing that um and then and
then here you are you've also sort of
written and produced your own work
what what insights into both worlds can
you share with us
um and should every sort of actor
screenwriter musician artist
should they be developing their own work
in addition to going the traditional
route
uh yeah i think so i mean if that's what
you want to do i mean
if you want to just be an actor then
just be an actor then then do everything
that comes across your path you know uh
web series blah blah blah just join a
theater group you know
uh but you know i i think it is you know
for a while i think the big thing was
one man show everybody was doing the
one-man show but it's always it's about
yeah mining your own life for maybe
profit
hopefully for fun but
uh
i i i don't think it can hurt again i i
i i i feel like
you just yeah you should you should you
should be writing your
dream screenplay or something
keep yourself keep yourself um
busy and focused in addition to your
career you're waiting for the agent call
or the audition that can be frustrating
sending out
you know head shots now we email them
thankfully but um it's still it's a lot
to um just kind of wait for someone to
discover you you know it's really uh it
doesn't happen a lot it happens of
course
but if you have a project or a theater
group or yeah a movie or a short film or
anything that you can do
separate from the uh
the
the hollywood uh
grid uh
i think you'll just benefit
do you think that what helped with the
depression was the fact that for once
you got to be in control with this
whereas it seems like being an actor
submitting you're just at the mercy of
other people yeah and you just really
felt empowered can you talk about yeah
uh you know i've always kind of
i've always kind of done
you know not a movie but you know like i
said i've had bands for years in college
i
did this play called the world of
wrestling that was like these
professional wrestlers we you know we
built the arena and you know separate
from the curriculum i've always kind of
done that even in
growing up i would put on productions of
the odd couple or a charlie brown
christmas with all my friends be the
director and we do you know
scenes from it so yeah i've always i
i've always kind of kind of done it i
mean in in a sense the depression um
took just the air out of everything and
i just i couldn't do anything anymore i
would i i think i stared at facebook for
like a year before i made like any kind
of comment and then now i'm of course
addicted and you know make too many
comments sometimes but um
but uh
it it's hard when you when the
depression happens um
to
do that so it just somehow
you can use it to to to get back but it
um
it you know it it it's of course as you
know when you're super depressed
you can't really say okay i'm going to
make a movie and you know
you know you want to but you're
incapacitated but maybe you start out
okay i'm gonna write a short story or a
song or whatever or take a class and you
know yeah build yourself up again but um
it's uh
it is something to it's a tool to to
help me and you know
were you scared that you weren't able to
complete the film for 5000
no i i wasn't i i
just once i just felt like i could do it
i i didn't think i was gonna run i i was
waiting for something crazy to like
some bizarre reason that
it wasn't gonna happen but just the way
i thought about it and
i
there just wasn't i i mean
it
yeah i i just i just knew i was going to
be able to do it i didn't know if it was
going to be good or or whatever but i
knew because i had a lot of experience
as a editor editing wedding videos i did
that for a few years just like non-stop
just like so i knew i could edit it too
and you know that um
that uh that's an interesting contention
with people i find like the second you
say oh yeah i edited the movie like oh
no you've got to get
an editor
he's got to
you can't you can't you know and there's
like first of all editor
you're like that you know i love that i
like that
first of all first of all editor is
gonna cost you thousands and thousands
of dollars for a good editor that's
gonna be able to dedicate the time the
hours and hours and hours which i
personally spent
on the movie after the film the filming
was easy that was the easy part the
editing it is i'm going to say like 75
of it is very labor-intensive
making the scenes all the shots all the
cuts
all you know the the dialogue the sound
the music you know it's it's a huge job
and um
and you know i i do say in the article
edit your own movie because uh for the
first one for whatever you can always
give it to somebody else people do that
all the time but if you're trying to
make a movie for five thousand dollars
uh unless like i said your wife or
somebody is an editor or
you're just
you can't do it like you can you can't
like i said in the movie too crew like
it's so hard to get people to be an
intern for free at this level you know
and it's so hard you could put a thing
on craigslist so edit my movie for free
for imdb credit but you're basically in
the same boat as if you edit it yourself
and
and when i say edit it you know and that
doesn't mean i didn't show it to anybody
and it's it's my vision and nobody and
i'm not listening to any changes that's
complete opposite i showed it to so many
people and even since since you've seen
it i think i've made quote the final
tweak to it but i but i constantly uh i
need input i wa i watched people watch
the movie and see if they reacted
where i wanted them to you know just
like a director and you know i'd put on
i just i i knew the movie had to be a
certain way and like because it's about
me and it's my music and a lot of things
it just didn't make sense for me to even
try and get an editor to explain it all
like i couldn't in the beginning of the
movie i'm in the shower i'm singing i'm
singing in the shower i'm singing a song
that we did a music video for
10 years before and i sort of knew that
when i was filming it
and i didn't know how it was going to
work out but it wasn't like an editor
wouldn't have known to like
cut from me to the shower right at a
certain point to the song
like the way it all entered
there's just no way i could explain it
and just how it went so it just didn't
make sense for me to
to
to get an editor now you know somebody
if you're a filmmaker you're not
technical you're not very technical and
you uh like i said you can get a good
crew of people and somebody can you want
somebody else to spend uh hundreds of
hours
literally pouring over the film and you
can afford it and sit around waiting for
them to call you to let you know when uh
they have an edit for you
uh fine but otherwise you're just gonna
be driving yourself crazy and you might
as well
learn
something about the software and even
the pacing of a movie and everything
that goes into a movie with your own
movie and if it fails you fail and if
somehow like i said you can get by the
end of it once you've done like the
majority of the labor
of the assemblage uh to come in and give
you give it this magic
tweak
um
you know go for it was we wrap up to our
last question here
what are you doing to prepare for the
screening on september 26th because this
is really
the sort of the hard part after the
editing i mean getting people in seats
oh god it was a tough thing it's super
hard super hard well the like i said
this uh
this was the launching point this day
it's it's just about a month right what
are we at the 28th yeah so we're at 26.
so like i said it just all worked i'm so
glad we moved the um the time of our
meeting so it kind of
felt you know um
felt like now i can yes and the facebook
page like i
the invite really start getting emails
start getting like i said stuff on indy
wire i write for a blog called unified
manufacturing great company that uh
does dvds and stuff and i do a blog for
them and i'm trying to
i'm going to do a big blast
with the publicist
um you know these are things that are
that that any filmmaker can can do once
you get a date for
a show you just you set up you a month
before you just
figure out every way
you can to get the word out without you
being annoying but
but
through um
through like i said you know
if you everybody knows somebody that has
a podcast or a blog
or a couple people start with your close
friends that they're always looking for
people you get practice to be on a show
and and and learn how to talk and
promote it's all it's all just
it's a lot of footwork you know but um
you know and hopefully it'll pay off but
but yeah i guess to answer your question
is yeah i'm really just
just
getting out there i i'm thinking of
doing a
publicity stunt
okay
all right uh involving the segway
you know the guitar
uh you know carefully placed sign
i'm thinking of going to like the
chinese theater i don't know you know
maybe just go down sunset boulevard
playing that thing on the segway from
hollywood to downtown maybe some reason
i'm visualizing you with like peanut
butter on your nipple well that might
that might happen too i wasn't getting
the peanut butter out for this but maybe
i should have peanut butter on them just
to you know you just want
you know
that's the next thing is yeah
if you're a filmmaker can you think of a
publicity stunt that if you do get
arrested you won't be thrown in jail but
maybe you'll get a ticket or we're just
in holding something and holding
too many people in the cell with you but
um well if you do that uh please let us
know so we could be there without i will
i know i think i'm gonna have to do it
now
i keep it's you know it was very
liberating to do that scene originally
in the movie um
uh yeah i have been thinking about
reenacting that awesome we've been
speaking with actor writer director and
musician steve more marco for more on
steve please visit abe
lincolnstory.com for his soul punk swing
band great intervention dot info first
film not the but just great
on facebook at steve moore marco and
also on facebook at the great
intervention
and more
markable.blogspot.com steve's blog yeah
more remarkable oh more i'm sorry okay
and more markable on twitter yeah
awesome there's so many ways to read
plenty of ways to reach it are you on
google plus
i am okay i'm i'm not sold on google
plus yet it's just like it's just it's
just not happening people sorry you know
we'll see
i'm there though come come talk to me on
there you know steve thank you so much
thank you thank you that was awesome you
know we talk to filmmakers each and
every week you know we often talk about
feature filmmaking it's still such an
extraordinary effort that goes into it
you know and congratulations thank you
you got your feature thank you yeah
that's really awesome
that's
that was the goal and i did achieve my
goal so everything else is just uh
you know frosting for more info go to
filmcars.com um type in the great
intervention in the search tab and i
guess in the meantime watch out there's
gonna be some sort of publicity stuff
i can't wait i want to actually post
photos i i i am going to do it i am
going to do it i have to figure out the
date to do it i think i might do it the
saturn it should i'm trying to decide
whether do it a few days before get it
up on youtube
probably like a week before at the end
of september we will i will be in touch
with you guys because you you if we do
it it it's got to be witnessed and also
congrats to you for also doing this at a
very difficult time in your life thank
you and and and working through that and
thank you for joining us
on another edition of film courage we
look forward to being here with you next
sunday at noon on la talk radio dot com
we will be joined by sherry candler john
reese and jeffrey winter to discuss
their book entitled selling your film
without selling your soul which is due
out in september by the great folks at
the film collaborative sherry candler
and john reese to find out more about
this amazing filmmaker resource please
visit
sellingyourfilm.com also visit
sellingyourfilm.com
blog for the books amazing trailer
and i have to ask are you a film courage
youtube listener or i'm sorry you a film
courage youtube
subscriber listener watcher whatever um
you know it's a great way to sort of
follow up interviews that we do here um
we have our outside the studio videos so
please um go to youtube.com
user i'm totally messing that up
youtube.com
user slash film courage i think that's
it and we may have an interesting uh
publicity stuff from steven until next
sunday have a great week